I often say that there's only four
things that are holding you back as a
human being one is if your vision and
goal is bigger than your self-image so
if you feel you deserve it you can have
this vision and goal and be excited
about and motivate about it you will not
do what it takes to achieve too if you
have limiting beliefs your limiting
beliefs will drive your behavior three
fear fear of being embarrassed to shame
ridicule to judge if you're a failure
fear of disappointment and the fourth
one by the way is you're lacking the
knowledge and skill required so that
actually sets up a self-doubt trigger
which activates the Frankenstein brain
which caused you to lose motivation but
most people prefer to master
disappointment and comfort zones instead
of mastering change so if I master
disappointment I know what I got I just
have to deal with oh okay this is what I
got and if I master my comfort zone then
at least this is the devil I know versus
mastering change and we know what's
going on in our brain we know what's
happening neurologically biologically
emotionally physically and all of that
is a skill why not just Master change
why not become an adaptationist right
now in the time that you need it the
most in the world if you don't then
you're just going to keep repeating the
same patterns so Master change now and
make that one of your core competencies
and then you master your life need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
John Assaraf and my take on his top 50
rules of success enjoy
we think about what is a limiting belief
like from a neuroscience perspective
when a neuroanatomist looks in your
brain right they can't see oh here's the
limiting belief pattern between here and
here but we do know that a limiting
belief is nothing more than a neural
network a pattern in the brain the
marbles connected right and if they've
connected and have been reinforced
often enough and strongly enough they
become part of something known as the
default mode Network we just default to
that belief why because we have enough
references to say this is true this
limiting belief that I'm not good enough
I'm not smart enough I'm too young I'm
too old I'm too Asian or Caucasian
somehow we have information and
experiences it says this is real
so we're operating from that
automatically we're operating from that
automatically but what does that really
mean what it means is not only does it
affect what we do or don't do but it
affects the land Ends by which we're
seeing the world we only see the world
through the lens of our empowering
beliefs or disempowering beliefs so
imagine if you had a lens whether it's
on your camera or on your glasses and
all of a sudden you put a coating on it
to take out all the blue light you're
not going to see the world the same yep
all the blue light is gone well limiting
beliefs or empowering positive beliefs
do the exact same thing if you think
about a radio and the radio is a good
example if you were on
98.5
let's say there's rock and roll on that
station at 98.9 there might be classical
music at
99.1 there might be big band okay music
so I do agree that when you get aligned
mentally and tune in to what it is that
you want
you're in resonance with that energy
field and there's millions of
frequencies okay all around us
so the first thing
is yes get totally cleared get totally
on the station of what you want to
achieve that's step one
if you're here and there and here and
there then you're on a variety of
different stations and I totally believe
that our brain emits a frequency based
on our predominant thoughts and emotions
and it also is in a receptive State when
you're practicing certain spiritual
practices or you're on that frequency
and you're on that channel so I do
believe in that that's called being in a
resonance but I do not believe for one
second that while we're sitting here in
this hotel room okay at The Encore Hotel
somebody's gonna knock on the door and
say John Nick you guys just want a
billion dollars because we are in
resonance no we we have to participate
in the process and do something to help
create that we have a hundred trillion
cells in our body I've had neck injuries
shoulder injuries meniscus injuries I've
had ankle injuries I've had I've had
injuries because I've always been pretty
athletic
um if you think about what is happening
every time I breathe in
I'm breathing in hydrogen oxygen
nitrogen carbon plus a whole bunch of
other elements from the air what do you
think your bones and tissues and muscles
are made of I'm eating you know let's
say I'm eating a protein whether it's
tofu or a piece of chicken right I'm
eating a protein that is making muscle
um eating fat I'm drinking water we are
made up of hydrogen oxygen nitrogen
carbon mostly and so every seven years
we're making a whole new body our
eyeballs are different our skeleton is
different our brain is not the same
cells that were in our brain seven years
ago our lungs liver heart tissues
nothing is the same
and so if I am
visualizing if I am meditating if I am
seeing a new healed bone if I'm seeing a
new healed uh part of my being
um is it possible that I can direct
some of what's happening in my body and
the answer is of course I can there are
so many people that have healed okay
from traumatic brain injuries from back
injuries from um from tears and all that
stuff and so I absolutely believe that
we can heal so that is that is my
opinion and we're we're just starting to
scratch the proverbial surface of what
our potential really is and starts with
our brain also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there the
research that that our neuroscientists
and neuropsychologists provide us with
is what drives Behavior what are
emotions what are feelings what are the
six core emotions that are processed at
the non-conscious level that give rise
to feeling see feeling is conscious
awareness of what I am experiencing in
my body
the emotion of anger disgust shame
happiness or fear is processed
non-consciously that gives
what an electrical signal that we feel
that's called feelings and so what we're
fascinated with is how are people
processing information that gives rise
to feelings which then causes people to
take action or not
so that's the kind of stuff I'm
fascinated with and then how can we help
somebody shift their perspective if you
change the way you look at something
the feeling changes
so if you change the meaning you change
the way you look at something the
feeling changes if the feeling changes
and we help people put their foot on the
gas instead of on the brake
then they're gonna take action and most
people I mean if everybody's watching
right now they're thinking why am I not
doing forget about learning anything new
why am I not doing the things I already
know I should be doing so A salesperson
you mentioned earlier you know they know
they should be prospecting why aren't
they prospecting more
like why not
well it's because something in their
brain
has got the break on why not discover
why
get your foot off the brake take action
so you may or may not know this story
yet but uh 10 years ago I was 238 pounds
33 body fat borderline hypertensive diet
almost full on Diabetes severe sleep
apnea not in good shape so I said listen
you've done okay in business you've done
okay with your relationship you're
happily married great this and that
um look at you you're you're a physical
mess
and so our words are really really
really critical because there's
something really important listening and
so if you're using words that you're
reinforcing if they're self-deprecating
words you're reinforcing a
self-deprecating self-image which means
Frankenstein brain is going to be
triggered by those words so if you think
about wait what is it every pound is 3
500 calories of energy
right and so when you think about what
do you do when you lose something what
have we been taught to do when we lose
something try and find it we'll find it
go get it back so if if weight is energy
I said to myself what do I need to do to
release this energy back into the
universe back in the form of hydrogenox
and nitrogen carbon whatever it is so
that somebody else who needs it right
now can use it it served me long enough
I'm ready to release it and to change
you know my physique to change how I
feel to change how I look and my goal
back then for my 50th birthday was to
get into the best shape of my adult life
for 50 which I did and then my goal is
to have a six pack at 60 which I'm
already there so I'm actually almost
there but the whole idea was the words
that I use right are really important
because they're the words that I listen
to and reinforce when we talk about the
word fear right so let me let me start
off with another you know little premise
here is um
most people are highly ignorant in
understanding what fear is
now I want to make sure people heard me
correctly ignorance doesn't mean you are
stupid ignorance means you just don't
know we're all ignorant we don't know
what we don't know well we don't know we
don't know and even the things that we
do know may not be accurate so when we
talk about fear there are 50 different
types of fear
all fear all fear is processed in the
subconscious mind
the automatic
neurochemistry that is created as a
result of the meaning that we give
certain things that cause us to either
be in a state or a fear or a stage of a
state of courageousness is all being
processed in our subconscious mind so
what causes fear for you doesn't cause
fear for me or for somebody else or may
cause fear in other people so whether
you know we're standing at the you know
top of a building that's a hundred
stories high some people look over and
don't have fear and other people do have
fear whether there's a giant 10-foot boa
constrictor you know in front of you may
cause fear in you that doesn't cause
fear in another person so it's never the
thing
that is causing the fear it's the
subconscious interpretation that we've
been conditioned to believe the meaning
that we learn to give something
determines whether the neurochemistry of
fear is activated that causes us to feel
a certain way so the feeling okay of of
being scared the feeling of being
uncertain this feeling of having
self-doubt the feeling of uh um of
having too much stress in our life that
is an effect
not a cause so feelings are conscious
our ability to be aware of this stuff
that's going on in our body that we
either know or don't know how to handle
or do anything with yeah so feeling is
conscious
fear is subconscious and so if for
example
we have you know one of the examples I
use is and you don't have this obviously
but if I ask a hundred people you know
do you have a fear of public speaking I
was just going to say that we're so I
was just going to say that I'm reading
your mind I'm reading your mind well
it's not your fear and that's what I'm
going to say so the actual fear is of
being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed or
judged so if we're afraid of being
embarrass the shame ridiculed or judged
that has nothing to do with the actual
public speaking it has to do with our
self-image and self-esteem and what we
think of ourselves and what we believe
others will say or think about us which
will affect our own self-image or
self-esteem let's say
you have um
something that you want to do a project
you want to finish a book you want to
write a business you want to start uh a
girl you want to call or walk across the
room or a guy
um you want to achieve a goal okay so if
you imagine that when you set your goal
you're activating the left prefrontal
cortex which I like to call is the
Einstein part of the brain the part of
your brain that can say what can I
imagine well I can imagine myself
achieving that goal I can imagine myself
making more money and living the
lifestyle of my dreams I can imagine
fill in the blank
so you set the goal so part one in the
brain is setting of the goal having that
vision for what you want we know uh up
until about 20 years ago
scientists believe that we were
hardwired so we were born we had certain
genetic propensities you're like your
mother like your father like your
grandparents and then you became a
little bit like you as a combination of
both those and your experiences well the
science was wrong right we just have
learned a lot more in the last 20 years
than we've known in the last 480 since
we began science and so the science of
neuroplasticity shows us that we're
consistently creating new connections
but but to leave it at that is is not
very useful so the question is like so
what right so what's a new connection
like what's the big deal and think about
this
um what baby was ever born with any
beliefs
none what born what baby was born with
any habits none what baby was born with
any prejudices
um at all or racist you know ideas none
what baby was born with any perspectives
or paradigms or have no no no no no and
so what happens is a baby is born with
about a hundred billion cells so think
about 100 billion cells like you would
100 billion marbles
and every time the marbles yeah so a lot
of marbles right that's why you lose
your marbles so so every time the baby
heard something saw something felt
something experienced something these
marbles made connections in their in
their brain and that's called
neuroplasticity the brain's ability to
create new connections and it's doing
that every second of every day and by
the time we're you know three four years
old we've gotten a lot of these neural
connections these beliefs and habits and
perspectives from our caregivers our
parents our brothers our sisters how
they treat us how we feel as we develop
these connections you know from zero to
three four the imprinting years you know
and then we have the modeling years
where we're modeling our parents from
you know two and a half three to five
six seven when we're dressing like them
and trying to put on their makeup which
I did too
um and so we're modeling now and then we
have our experiential years where we
gain some of our own experiences and we
are creating these new Connections in
our brain that be become our map of the
world here's how the world works you
know uh white people are this black
people are that when I when I put my
finger in this socket it feels really
bad so don't do it more than once you
know when I eat this I like it and you
know when I see this I laugh and and
when I do this it hurts and so we
develop this model of the world and we
develop our beliefs about money about
relationships about career about travel
about food we develop all of this stuff
um you know by the millions and millions
and millions of connections every hour
and then it slows down after we're about
10 or 12 years old so we have this map
this road map of reality
and based on our parents and caregivers
and grandparents and teachers and
television and whatever we experienced
some of that map is accurate and some of
that map is not some of those beliefs
are accurate some of them are not some
of the habits we developed are
constructive and some are destructive
right but from a neuroscience
perspective they're nothing more than
just connections between one marble or
another
now here's the good news great news
actually we can deliberately create our
own connections now because we know that
this science of neuroplasticity says
that if we take let's say an affirmation
I'm so happy and grateful that I am more
and more confident each and every day so
it may not sound real initially when you
say that but that's because you've said
it one time and the connection is weak
but if you said that a hundred times or
500 times or a thousand times and then
you felt it and then you went out and
did a couple little things to give you
some confidence let's say you're shy and
you just went to um I don't know a
coffee shop and you just smiled at
somebody and nodded to them didn't
necessarily were just smile then not and
they smiled and nodded back and go oh
wow that didn't hurt they didn't hurt me
they didn't say anything bad about me
they didn't embarrass me they didn't try
to shame me they didn't try to make me
feel guilty and if you did that enough
for a day a week a month three months
all of a sudden you'd be in inner sizing
your self-confidence muscle and the
shyness starts to go away a little bit
at first and then it's like wow this
isn't a dangerous place have you ever
considered that imagination
um creativity logic uh Focus
concentration self-esteem self-worth
tenacity resolve have you ever
considered that those are neuro muscles
we have biceps triceps shoulders uh
chest buttocks uh muscles for your
physical body have you ever considered
that you have neuromuscles
have you ever considered that creativity
is a neuro muscle that you can utilize
one of the first things that I learned
at a
thankfully enough a young age through my
mentors was failure is just feedback and
separate you as a human being from what
you've tried that fails so don't connect
if you fail at things that there's
something wrong with you so I was
fortunate that you know I've failed and
I've always failed forward and I said
what's the lesson what did I learn and
it just made me better so I've had you
know a lot of great great opportunities
for learning one of the things that
people are whoops making a big big
mistake on is they are trying to master
a lot of channels like I do right now
when they should be mastering One
Channel first so should you
Master Facebook and creating a little
tribe in communities should you master
advertising on Facebook
should you
Master YouTube because you enjoy videos
like I do and creating videos is easy
for you and you can talk about your
product your service your knowledge your
skills that people want to understand
because the people who watch YouTube
is a very different profile than the
person who watches or is on Facebook and
in many cases the people that are on
Facebook aren't paying attention to
Instagram right
so you have to master one thing first
based on your knowledge your skills and
your abilities and your budget
right so when I go live and do a session
here you know I have a team that's
behind me I've got people that can
manage the controls like if I had to
manage all the controls and go live on
all these uh channels that would be
difficult for me but speaking and then
getting onto all the channels that's
easy so which is the channel that you
are going to get really good at because
there's millions of people prospects who
could want your product or service and
if you're trying to be everything to
everyone on all the challenge channels
chances are you're going to diffuse your
energy instead of focus your energy so
let me give you an example
sunlight right so if you are outside and
it's sunny you can get a nice little tan
right but if you take a magnifying glass
hold on look where's my magnifying glass
oh I have one here somewhere if you take
a magnifying glass you can take the
sunlight and you can take a piece of
paper right and you could magnify that
same energy and burn a hole in the paper
you can take that same sunlight and
reduce it to single photons and you can
cut through a laser so instead of doing
a little bit here and a little bit there
and a little bit there and a little bit
there
why not master if you have limiting
beliefs like you're not good enough not
worthy enough you don't have enough
money knowledge skills you're too young
you're too old neural patterns in your
brain is what beliefs are and we have
constructive ones destructive ones
empowering ones disempowering ones
positive and negative neural patterns
called beliefs
the key is to deactivate the beliefs
that disempower you and to create a new
belief that matches the vision and goal
you have then we have the fears I talked
about I'm going to give you a couple
techniques
if you have a fear of having a goal and
failing
you're not going to take action because
as soon as that circuit turns on for the
failure circuit which is the fear
circuit and guess what happens all of
the motivation that you had goes out the
window and you either fight Freeze or
flee meaning running away doing
something else like procrastinate
instead of doing what you need to do so
if you have a fear of failure a fear of
success a fear of being embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed or judged these are
going to turn off your motivational
centers and activate your fear centers
so
I'm not going to leave you hanging
without a solution
first and foremost understand that you
and I became conditioned because of our
parents our teachers television radio
our experiences well we heard what we
saw what meanings we gave things which
means that we became conditioned we
weren't born with any beliefs or fears
of self-image challenges
we developed them and in neuroscience
and neuropsychology terms means that we
developed the patterns that God
reinforced to become the natural easy
way for us to be even though we may not
want it so
what if you wrote down a limiting belief
that you had okay I'm not smart enough
not good enough not worthy I don't have
the money I don't have the time I don't
have this I'm too young I'm too old
write out whatever you want
and then what if you just created a new
language pattern and reframed it and
said in the past I used to believe fill
in the blank and now I believe that I am
smart enough I am good enough I am
worthy I can achieve this I can't find
the money I can upgrade my knowledge I
can upgrade my skills and I'm excited
and enthusiastic to achieve the vision
and goal of and right in the blank now
if you wrote that out
and you repeated it and emotionalized it
and felt it as if you were a Hollywood
actor or actress learning a new role you
would activate something called the
neuroplasticity switch in your brain
that would cause new neurons to connect
and if you reinforced it for the next
Hundred Days by reading it
emotionalizing it recording it and
listening to it you would take a new
pattern that you wrote out and then you
would impress it through space
repetition repetition okay is what is
required in order to strengthen and
reinforce a neural pattern and practice
is what makes permanent let me repeat
practicing a paragraph or an affirmation
of what you want is what makes permanent
what that means is it makes the neural
network permanent and it replaces the
old pattern it takes 66 days to 365 days
to do this so don't do it for for a week
going nothing's happening
66 days to 365 days that's for limiting
beliefs slow down
and create plans let me explain when I
was younger
I would take
every single day as a challenge to get
as many things as I could done however I
didn't take the time to really focus on
the things that were going to make the
biggest impact in my business I gave
everything the same value and so yes I
was busy yes I was getting things done
but if I could go back in time I would
focus on what is the plan that's going
to move me down the road to achieve the
business success that I want faster and
easier versus versus harder and more
complex and now
as I am almost going to be 60. I think
about time and I've done some videos in
the past on there's no such thing as
time management all you can do is manage
what you do in time but in order to know
what you should do in time you have to
think about what are the objectives that
you want to achieve in your business and
in business there's obviously sales
marketing Finance Management product
development technology
Etc but there are certain things that
you need to do before you do the other
things and what I've discovered is we
tend to gravitate towards the things
that interest us and are easy for us to
do but business isn't like that in
business there are critical things that
you have to do if you're serious about
building a business that actually works
for you instead of you working for it so
one of the things
that is really really important is that
you take the time to find out what are
the building blocks for your type of
business whether you're online or
offline whenever you're looking to to
grow spiritually emotionally mentally
physically uh there's going to be
lessons involved and if you don't learn
the lesson you're going to repeat it
that's number one but more importantly
when you're doing things on planet Earth
in the Physical Realm you have to do the
right things in the right order at the
right time and nature doesn't care about
whether you make mistakes or not you are
going to pay the consequences of those
mistakes
and so when we make errors in our
judgment or we make errors in our timing
or we make errors in our tactics we pay
the consequences and that's just part of
the game and I personally believe that
we're playing in a Precision model game
and so there's nothing that's out of
order in the universe so if nothing's
out of order my job is to be in
resonance with the order
that already exists and that is for me
resonance or
um you know chaos so I don't look at it
as attraction I don't think that we
attract you know stuff to us though the
the way most people think about it is
that resonance though because you know I
believe we live in an energetic world is
the resonance based on a frequency or a
vibration yeah so if you sit at the
piano and you hit the a440 key
chances are that the chandelier that's
in resonance with that is going to start
vibrating even though there's no strings
between the two so through the medium of
air anything that's in resonance is in
this attractive state or in this
coherence state by the same token if you
hit the A330 key you're not going to hit
that chandelier frequency and the same
is true with the tuning fork right so if
you have a tuning fork and you hit a
certain key The Tuning Fork will start
to vibrate that's resonance a lot of
people think well that's attraction no
it's not attraction it's not it doesn't
work that way from all the research that
I have mustered so my job
um and we get into some of the brain
stuff is if you think about a radio
if you turn on a radio and you want to
hear 95 point or if you want to hear
classical music you might go to 95.5 and
it tunes into a frequency that's already
here
it's not attracting it it's already here
if you don't like classical music you go
to 103.3 and you have punk rock it's
already here so how do we use that as a
corollary relationship to if my brain is
the world's most sophisticated
electromagnetic switching station is it
possible that I can tune into
frequencies of what's already here and
the answer is yes that's resonance and
so we can tune in on a spiritual
emotional mental and physical level and
when you create that coherence then all
of a sudden you start to be in the
awareness of everything that's already
here that you weren't in coherence with
before and people say well I must be
attracting it no no no it was already
here how do you
stand out from the competition I want
you to think about this and this is
based on Seth godin's book called Purple
Cow I want you to imagine you're walking
okay in the country area and often the
distance you see a herd of cows
and big deal there's just cows but what
would you do if one cow was purple
what would you do if one cow was purple
you'd go holy sh look at the Purple Cow
let me ask you a question
when people look at your product or your
service your offering whether it's on
your website your landing pages radio
television Billboards uh when you speak
do they go holy mackerel that's unique
that's different that I have to pay
attention to
right do they say that
right and so Miriam is saying I would
pay attention to that cow right why
because it's different it's it's Unique
so biggest mistake that people make in
2021 that I want you to stop is I want
you to think okay if you just start to
think about you know what can I do to
stand out like a purple cow
that'll put you ahead of 90 of business
owners right now because they don't
figure that out they don't understand
that in order to clear through the
Clutter of all the noise
you have to stand out first every single
brand has an identity and the identity
comes with it you know a certain color
uh a certain way of being an identity
means something to people
right so when you are thinking about you
as your personal brand
what is the identity of your brand
right is it uh is it Mercedes-Benz or
Volkswagen is it Adidas or Nike you know
is it uh bright colors or dull colors
every brand has an identity and you have
to choose okay when you are building
your personal brand an identity that
resonates with who you are when you're a
personal brand
you have to be an authentic you
and so in order for your brand to show
up as you okay what does your brand say
about you so here's the couple here are
a couple of questions that
you may consider uh many of you have
followed my work for quite some time
would you agree that there's a
consistent theme about what I teach and
how I teach it
right is there a consistent theme around
mindset around skill set and around
action set do you notice that if you
followed my work you know for a year or
two or three or four you know I
specialize on the neuroscience and
neuropsychology of success that's my
theme my underlying theme if you've
noticed
another part of my brand is consistency
right so I show up Tuesdays every
Tuesday right here at nine o'clock
um Pacific time which is San Diego
right so when you are thinking about
your personal brand I want you to take
out a sheet of paper and I want you to
write down what does your personal brand
look like if you take a look at you know
my book you know inner size okay my
newest best-selling book not not the
answer but inner size if you take a look
at having it all if you take a look at
the colors you know in my office on the
wall right look at that the colors on
the wall
if you take a look
at the colors
you know of my company neurogym there's
a consistency of colors right
right there's a consistency of colors
and so one of the things that you have
to understand when you're developing a
personal brand is your your developing
coherence in somebody's brain around
your colors your theme what you stand
for what you're all about and so the
first thing to consider when you're
developing your personal brand
is first to Define what is your personal
brand how specifically am I going to
achieve that goal like what are the
strategies and the tactics meaning what
are you going to do how specifically are
you going to do it by when
right so now when we have you know an
attitude of goal achievement of getting
clear on the goal coming up with what
I'm going to do on Monday at nine
o'clock and here's how I'm going to do
it and here's whose help I need I'm
going to put it right into my calendar
and I'm going to take inspired action
and when an obstacle comes in my way I'm
going to ask myself empowering questions
like
how can I overcome this obstacle what
can I do to overcome this obstacle whose
help do I need what book can I read what
do I need to search on Google what
YouTube video can I watch to overcome
this obstacle where can I learn better
strategies and tactics to make what I do
more efficient more productive more
constructive versus me just working hard
and long trying to do what to do
there's a formula called PPP equals PPP
and it goes like this piss poor planning
equals piss-poor performance and many
people
I have found don't have any real plans
for what they're going to do today this
week this month this quarter they show
up every morning okay without a road map
to go from where they are to where they
want to be by the end of the day
so what are you going to do today
to achieve your health goals your wealth
goals your relationship goals your
career goals your business goals your
fun goals the experiences you want your
charitable goals what are you going to
do today or this week to move yourself
forward to make progress every single
day then what are you going to do to
manage your mindset and your emotions
what are you going to do to overcome the
obstacles that are in your area whether
they're mental obstacles physical
obstacles Financial obstacles
strategical obstacles tactical obstacles
now you may be watching me right now
going oh my God there's so much stuff
there well yeah if you want to achieve
goals
there's a thinking there is a feeling
and there's a behavior that gets you
there and there's also a thinking a
feeling in a behavior that does not get
you there most people you know confuse
activity with productivity they confuse
setting goals from achieving goals they
don't understand that you have to create
some kind of a road map to reduce the
resistance and uncertainty and stress
and fear and anxiety in your brain so
that you activate your motivational
centers
a motive for Action Center in your brain
so that you actually take action instead
of repeating your old patterns over and
over again when I first learned about
the law of attraction I was 19 years old
but I was taught that with the law of
attraction also is the law of Goya and
nobody talks about the law of Goya I've
been around is that Christian people no
no but the law of Goya is the get off
don't marry a Jewish girl that was the
love that's awesome
no there's a lot of boys that get off
your ass law right and so a lot of
people who think about this Law of
Attraction stuff is is you know sit
there like a monk you know and meditate
and visualize and belief and write your
goals down and that's gonna happen for
you and it's [ __ ] it's just raw
[ __ ]
um I don't have any friends zero that
don't bust their ass
on in pursuit of what they want
in addition to being in resonance with
it and and attracting it they are
busting their ass every day every week
every month every quarter every year ups
and downs highs and lows things that
work things that don't and they keep
moving forward to make it happen and
they find along the way they get some
lucky breaks when you're developing new
habits I want you to develop small
repeatable consistent
easy let me repeat small repeatable
consistent easy things to do for a new
habit for 100 days
if you want to become a person who reads
a lot
read one sentence or one paragraph a day
for a hundred days
preferably around the same time if you
want to start exercising to be healthier
I want you to start exercising for one
freaking minute a day for 100 days or 30
seconds or three minutes you choose the
minimal possible uh behavior that you
can do to develop the Habit The Habit is
more important than the intensity
at first you want to reduce all the
neurological stress of change you want
to reduce all the neurological processes
that are built for you to conserve
energy and not develop new habits so you
have to create a new habit Loop
and the way you do that is small
repeatable easy consistent behaviors for
100 days don't worry about anything
other than that if you want to develop a
new thought pattern
think in a certain way every day for 100
days and schedule a time create your own
trigger when you wake up when you go to
sleep after sex uh before the bathroom
before you brush your teeth whatever it
is
if you can just commit to small little
behaviors for 100 days
you'll develop the foundation of a new
habit where you do the Habit then the
Habit creates you let me give an example
what if I said to you hey uh Joel let's
do this business venture together you
put up 20 grand I'll put up 20 grand
you'll take care of podcasting sales
marketing networking I'll take care of
this this and that and um and let's do
this together we probably get excited
um well what would happen if you start
to think about well what if it doesn't
work what if I don't deliver this what
if I can't do this what if uh you know I
lose my money what if I do that and
that's a normal discussion to have what
if I told you by the way after we do the
deal here's the way you're going to
think you're going to have a whole bunch
of these negative thoughts you're gonna
have a whole bunch of these negative
emotions you're gonna have a whole bunch
of these Sensations that you want to
move away from and that's going to be
normal here's what I want you to do flip
the switch flip from this right
prefrontal cortex which is supposed to
do that for you and let's flip you over
to the left prefrontal cortex which is
the genius part of your brain I'm going
to say okay great when that happens I
want you to flip the switch like that
and shift over and see both sides if we
do invest together if we do execute a
plan if we do what we say we're going to
do is it possible that we will hit our
income goals hit our our net revenue
bills be able to do this and this and
this and this and this and this and this
and this and as soon as you can help
somebody make that switch Jeff from one
part of the brain that's the pessimistic
we call it the Frankenstein part of the
brain and the other side is the
optimistic strategic thinker that can
connect to all possibilities at all
times and that's the left prefrontal
cortex and that's where the genius part
of you is and that's why I have Mr
Albert Einstein there to always remind
me activate left prefrontal cortex and
be aware of a right prefrontal cortex
which is for the most part just bringing
up memories from my 55 years on this
planet The Good the Bad and the Ugly
yeah so it's a Frankenstein and Einstein
I like it
when I when when Einstein is working you
are dreaming in the world of
possibilities how can I what can I do
who can I talk to how will it work what
should I read and who should I network
with what are the possibilities what are
the tools that you want the resource I
need and all the possibilities open up
pay myself first let me explain when I
first started Re Max of Indiana
even though money was coming into the
company I wasn't taking any money out
and I worked for for months and years on
end you know just putting everything
back in the business and that created a
lot of stress in the early years and so
what I would do differently now is I
would value myself more and I would take
an income or take a percentage of the
revenues on an ongoing basis so that I
got paid for the services that I
provided to my business now when you put
yourself up on the pedestal where you
deserve and you pay yourself you
actually build your self-confidence you
build your self-worth you build your
self-esteem and you get paid for the
services rendered when you pay everybody
else first
you are putting everybody else in front
of you and you are the number one person
that you need to keep motivated and it
doesn't matter how much it is that you
pay yourself it has to be something for
the effort and the work that you do so
at least you build your own self-worth
and value a lot of times when we are
focusing on what we've lost
or what we're losing we're not focusing
on what we've gained a lot of times
we're focusing okay on what's possible
as a result of this we we tend to Mono
Focus right on either good or bad I like
it I don't like it it tastes good it
doesn't it's hurting me it's not but
what if you could learn how to observe
both
what if you could observe the law of
polarity in its entirety that says you
cannot have an electron without a proton
and in without an out and up without a
noun you cannot have that on this planet
in this universe
so is it possible that with just a
little bit of training whether it's
mindfulness or meditation or awareness
you can be sad
you can grieve
and be joyful and happy at the same time
see it's when we are afraid that we're
losing something
that we've got that Frankenstein brain
of ours saying what if what if what if
what if oh my God oh my God oh my God oh
my God oh my God when we are in that
state we can't be focused on what are we
going to do about it now in a grieving
State like with my mother
um the only thing I want to do about is
make sure that we respect and honor her
life and my brothers and sisters and my
dad Etc so I need to focus on that and
when we're talking about you know a
business going under a relationship you
know that's unraveling right now
if you're focusing on all of the
disempowering emotions and circumstances
you cannot be focusing on the solution
to that possible problem so you have to
learn how to manage the emotions and for
those who don't know what that's like I
want you to imagine I just gotta really
imagine
oh a Hollywood actor or actress learns
that they are not their emotions they
have emotions
now everybody's going to grieve
differently
but I want people to understand that you
don't have to be disempowered in grief
you could be empowered in grief and
everybody's going to do it differently
and some people are going to go inside
some will go outside but we have the
ability to frame things in ways that
Empower us and gives us the best chance
to move forward instead of being a
victim of it
and all I'm saying is consider consider
that you have way more power than you
are displaying in your emotional
Management in your focus in your
awareness and in your behavior and you
can feel the entire spectrum of emotions
totally cool with that but are you being
constructive versus destructive in your
behaviors cognitive priming right so
what's cognitive time so think about
this when um a baby is learning how to
eat okay what does you know Mommy or
Daddy do mommy or daddy you know takes
the spoon and you know she puts it in
the jar she pretends to eat it herself
and then she puts it into the baby's
mouth open the mouth and she does that
to cue the baby's brain of what to do so
she pretends she's doing it herself she
gets the baby to do it and through this
repetition a baby will learn spoon in
the hand in the jar spoon has food on it
mommy's opening her mouth she's bringing
it to me open my mouth I put the food in
my mouth oh this yummy thing feels so
good um
eat this food and so if you think about
what's actually happening we're getting
the motor cortex of her brain going
we're getting her taste buds going you
know at a certain point we'll put the
spoon in her mouth and put her hand in
the jar so that she could do it for
herself so we're priming her through
Visual cues through auditory cues
through taste cues right through all of
the different senses we're priming her
brain and then we're reinforcing it day
after day after day after day to create
the neural network the connections in
the brain that if I want that yummy food
in my mouth I have to learn how to take
the spoon in my hand put it in the jar
get it all over the place initially
until I could do it without spilling it
all over the place well that takes you
know weeks and months and years to tie
your shoes to learn how to eat to learn
how to brush your teeth all these things
that are automatic now yeah all the
things that are automatic now so before
something's automatic it's not yeah and
it can feel really uncomfortable so so
let's take
um
a disempowering belief that you have I'm
not good enough I'm not smart if I'm too
young I'm too old I'm female I'm
whatever it is you have a disempowering
belief it's a nothing more than a
pattern in the brain so somehow a
pattern that wasn't there before got
there
right who told you that your parents
your teachers your brother your sister
your best friend said ah you'll never
remember like who did that it's really
irrelevant but if the pattern is there
and it's a dominant pattern because
you've believed it for 20 30 40 years
whatever the case might be and it's been
reinforced
what does brain science say about how
the do I get rid of it and it says well
you'll never get rid of it but you can
deactivated okay how do I deactivate it
right how do I deactivate it so every
time I catch myself saying I'm not good
enough or fill in the blank feel take
any limiting belief and anytime you
catch yourself saying it or feeling it
what if you said to yourself
stop
in the past I used to believe that and
now I believe I'm more than good enough
in the past I used to feel like I'm too
young but now I can use my age as a
benefit to achieve that goal
any limiting belief we can do one of a
couple things we can say in the past I
used to
and so what we're doing is we're not
saying no stop that we're not
reinforcing a limiting belief by trying
to fight it we acknowledge it's just a
pattern embracing it and just say in the
past I used to believe that and now
here's what I'm choosing to believe so
now what I'm doing is I'm taking an
existing neural pattern and I'm changing
the pattern I'm taking away its
energetic Force by adding new words that
I'm choosing Now versus the ones that
were given to me or the ones that I felt
when I was too young to actually change
it on my own then so now I'm paying
attention to my self-talk I'm paying
attention I'm paying attention to the
inner critic let's say you know you and
I are buddies we want to start a
business or we have a busy come on let's
crush it all right let's do this thing
let's triple our income this year let's
make 30 more net revenues let's travel
the world let's live this lifestyle
that's amazing and we get excited right
so we go oh yeah oh my God that's great
let's do this high fives all around
dopamine's release we feel great we
shared with our friends we release
oxytocin so we bonded oh my God I love
you and you love me and we feel great
we're going to conquer the world
and that happens all the time
but let's say that underneath the hood
there's
a fear of
I'm not smart enough
or I'm not good enough or what if I fail
and I embarrass myself what if I succeed
and I can't maintain it what if I'm
ridiculed because I try so hard and my
friends will laugh at me
there are 50 5-0 different types of
fears that are almost in everybody's
memory bank that gets brought up to the
surface and when the fear circuit lights
up which is Bam automatically within
either moments hours or days when you
start realizing holy [ __ ] what is it
going to really take to double or triple
my income into and to take the time off
that I want as soon as that happens
when the fierce circuit lights up then
the system the the neuroelectrical
chemical system floods with epinephrine
cortisol and norepinephrine what is that
those are just three of the hundred
chemicals in the brain
that are part of the stress response
system whenever you and I and everybody
watching or listening
thinks about or feels that there's
potential danger potential pain whether
it's emotional pain like being
embarrassed or ashamed or financial pain
like not being able to have enough money
to pay for my food or for my burger or
for my cocktails or for my rent or my
car or my airline ticket if there is
real or imagined
possibility of discomfort pain
the break on motivation slams shut
and we start to procrastinate
so we have this incredible system that
can give us this motivation the motive
for Action to go forward but we have to
temper it with our ability to recognize
the trigger and the sensation in our
body called a Feeling
that the non-conscious processing part
of the brain that gives us this emotion
called fear all fear is processed at the
non-conscious level of your awareness
and then gives rise into the frontal
lobes
of the feeling that your body has the
average person that has not been trained
feels fear and puts the break on and
goes and Retreats into what they're
comfortable doing
the successful person either they may be
genetically wired to understand feeling
fear and doing it anyway turning Their
Fear into fuel but that's not the
majority of people that's why 90 plus
percent of people fail and stay in that
position but you can take that fuel that
hypersensitive Rocket Fuel I call it and
utilize it to actually motivate you
faster further than you ever got before
yeah fascinating systems if you don't
know how to use them too bad it's like
not knowing that a gun has got bullets
in it and you pull the trigger the holy
[ __ ] just blew my brains out
not that you'd be able to you know say
that you'd be like game over but
ignorance is not your friend when it
comes to neurochemistry at the time I
was 22 years old trying to work trying
to make make money and I wanted to
figure out what was causing my
ulcerative colitis because the also rate
of colitis was an effect
all right so I was like what was causing
it and what I realized was causing it
was a lot of stress the wrong Foods too
much alcohol no exercise
Etc so I said okay well how could I heal
myself and at the time I was taking 25
pills a day I was doing enemas in the
morning enemas at night and going to the
hospital once a month for them to stick
a tube in my rectum to see what was
happening in my colon not fun at 22
years old it's like what the
front door right and so I said okay let
me see if I could really heal myself and
so I wrote an affirmation I wish I had
it here because I'd read you it says my
body in all its organs were created by
the infinite intelligence in my
subconscious mind it created all my
bones tissues muscles uh liver lungs
heart and everything else within me it
knows how to heal me I am now perfectly
healthy that's a short version of that
and every day in addition to eating well
exercising sleeping well I would read
this affirmation I would close my eyes I
would see my colon heel I would see my
colon sick I'd see my colon heel I'd see
my colon six sick I'd see my colon heel
that that's called mental contrasting in
the world of Neuroscience
and so I would see this over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and over and over and over in my
brain I would read it I would feel it I
would see it
five weeks of doing this after two and a
half years of being sick
all of my symptoms went away a hundred
percent when I went in to see my doctor
his name was Dr Wu he said to me you've
had a spontaneous remission I said it's
not a spontaneous remission it was a
deliberate remission that was 36 years
ago all right and the doctor says
whatever you're doing you know keep
doing he says but I want you to still
take the pills I was taking 25 pills a
day I said to him I said Doctor Who you
don't understand do you I said I fixed
the cause you still want to treat the
symptom
right and so I have shown people how to
get off of colitis Crohn's disease
diverticulitis our body is consistently
remanifesting itself based on our
thoughts emotions feelings Sensations
and behaviors so what if everyone would
watch you what if I could be in a
vibration mentally
heart-wise right emotionally and gut
wise so heart brain heart and gut what
if I can create alignment so that I am
in a state of health so my body is
regenerating healthy cells my body is
regenerating you know or activating
energy from my mitochondria what if I
could be in this alignment with the flow
of Health versus a flow of dis ease so
for you
you know what happens with most people
is they're focusing on their dis-ease or
their pain instead of channeling their
attention and energy and focusing on
health and well-being so the more you
say you know my neck is broken my neck
is broken I've got a little thing in my
neck it's painful in my neck the doctors
say I can't uh this is impossible the
more you keep reinforcing the cellular
activity that reinforces that when the
fear signal has kicked in
all right it's releasing the
neurochemicals like I said epinephrine
cortisol norepinephrine which is
adrenaline
um and some of it's good too much of it
will cause you to fight to freeze to
flee run away or defaint those are the
four okay possible outcomes for the
stress response or fear response system
when it kicks in so when that switch is
turned on think of it as a light switch
that just turned on in your brain and
then there's a Cascade okay of
neurochemicals that causes a feeling if
you focus on the feeling then you're
going to think about what you feel then
you're going to feel what you think
about and you create this
self-fulfilling Doom Loop of
neurochemicals being rushed in your body
and if you do that every day every week
every month over and over again you've
now just set up a doom Loop habit where
that fear is going to drive of your
thoughts and emotions and behaviors or
lack thereof but what I want you to do
is recognize the fear
calmly and you do this as soon as you
recognize the fear that you can bring up
on your own you do the first inner size
okay in their size exercise for your
physical body and your organs inner size
for your neuro muscles all right so
when you feel fear be in observation of
it like the light comes on in the dash
of your car and then what you do is you
take six deep breaths but here's how you
do it
in through your nose out through your
mouth like you're blowing out of a straw
so it goes like this six breaths 10
seconds each ready
deep rhythmic breaths in up in the lungs
expand the diaphragm so you get the
diaphragm and the lungs expanding
and you breathe out like you're
breathing through a straw so you focus
the energy
out through the mouth it causes your
brain to actually get oxygenated and
guess why you want that well when we're
in a state of fear we activate
okay the vagus nerve which constricts
your blood flow it slows down your
heartbeat it causes shallow breathing so
as soon as you alternate from that fear
and stress response system to the calm
the I'm sorry from the from the stress
and react system to the calm and
response system your brain shuts off the
fear circuit and activates the left
prefrontal court exam where you can
think because blood flows back there
again so if fear is holding you back
there's nothing wrong with fear but
there just be maybe
um a lack of skill of knowing when or
what to do does this make sense so far
does this make sense so far so when you
take those six deep rhythmic breaths
that is what deactivates that stress
response system in the brain and
activates the relax and respond you want
to be in a responsive State as much as
possible versus a reactive State one of
the
um I guess most unbelievable discoveries
of the last hundred years is that our
brain can create new neural connections
new beliefs new habits new perceptions
um new
um neural muscles and reinforced neural
muscles and so if you look at the
problem she says with curiosity and with
this approach she says a lot of people
focus on debt and they go oh my God look
at the debt I'm in how am I going to get
out uh here's the problem I can't pay
this I can't do this she knows now when
you sit down and you look at the debt
and you write down you brainstorm how to
get out of debt and make more wealth and
write down every idea that you can come
up with she goes you activate the
creativity neural muscle and the more
you practice it
the more you teach yourself how to focus
on the solution instead of the problem
the more you're flipping your
neuroplasticity switch but the more
you're flipping on your curiosity
imagination and creativity circuits
training your brain is so critical you
can train your brain to be aware acutely
aware of your senses of what are my
Sensations what's my heartbeat doing
right now what's my breathing doing
right now am I anxious and nervous and
stressed is my sympathetic nervous
system activated
or am I calm relaxed able to think
clearly can I respond instead of being
in this reactive State when the
sympathetic nervous system has kicked in
you're in your flight or fight response
mechanism so you're breathing shallowly
your tense your heart beats elevated you
might feel like you're sweating a little
bit and it's just tense and
parasympathetic is calm observe pay
attention be aware be mindful choose
deliberately versus reactively if
somebody's unhappy Could you teach
yourself to be happy in less than three
seconds and the answer is yes if you
chose to so control of emotion control
of emotions and so when we focus on the
the core emotions people have of
Happiness sadness shame uh discuss
contempt love uh we can learn how to
switch between those
on any given moment but most people what
happens they get caught up in this
emotion energy and motion that's
negative or disempowering and then they
think about how they feel and they feel
what they're thinking about and they
keep perpetuating the same pattern and
that's not where it ends and this is
where the problem lays is if you do that
on a regular basis your brain says since
you're repeating this let me just make
this
um you know a habit and I'll just create
that on commemori so you're in that
state more frequently let's say you have
a goal okay any goal um I'm a financial
goal a travel goal a net worth goal have
my own blog post or blog and and have a
tribe follow me goal and that's your
vision and your goal that you've
consciously chosen
but then beneath the surface
you feel
am I really worthy of that
am I really good enough am I really
smart enough do I really deserve that
anytime you have a vision or a goal that
is positive and and fun and amazing but
there is a subconscious
negative or disempowering pattern like
self-esteem self-worth or self-image the
negative disempowering pattern wins 98
of the time wow so if you think about
the positive vision and goal as being
the you know the positive if we have the
positive and the negative we have chaos
in the brain and what we really want to
create more of is coherence so what's
coherence well imagine you um if
everybody just think about going to your
favorite band your favorite band's
coming to town all right and you are so
excited because you just love to hear
them but
um they're drummer or their lead
vocalist or their guitarist got sick a
few days ago and they had to get
somebody else to play you know tonight
when you're going to see them play
and they haven't had a chance to
practice together and this new band
member is just not in tune with
everybody else there's going to be chaos
it's like oh he's off the vocals are off
or where the piano's off or the guitar
is off it just doesn't sound right or
feel right and the whole thing's off
it's off so it's like the experience is
like there's no Harmony here right so
when people's Vision or goals are out of
harmony with their subconscious
self-esteem or fears or limiting beliefs
there's chaos and there isn't there's
too much friction and the action in the
absence of
um of friction you have smooth but when
there's friction there it's just not
smooth it's not in harmony it's like a
muscle your brain has neural muscles
okay right so if you think about you
know we have if we want to build our
bicep muscle or our chest or our
shoulders or our legs we go to the gym
we do exercises or we go and Hike or run
or bike or walk or or do whatever it is
well what do you do to strengthen your
your confidence muscle what do you do to
strengthen your self-esteem muscle what
do you do to strengthen your tenacity or
resolve muscle what do you do to to
strengthen any of your core neural
muscles like awareness how do you
strengthen your awareness how do you
strengthen your ability to focus and
stay laser
disciplined on an achievement of a goal
these are all neural muscles that you
can strengthen but nobody up until now
has come up with here are the inner
sizes for your neural muscles instead of
the exercises for your physical muscles
until neurogym and inner size the first
inner size that you teach anyway it's
kind of like learning the alphabet first
so take six calm the circles there's
three foundational inner sizes we teach
in the book there's many more but the
first one is just to deactivate the
stress reactive Center in the brain and
you do that through six deep breaths in
10 second increments so you take a deep
breath in through your nose
and then as you blow out pretend you're
blowing out through a straw so all of
your energy is towards that Focus right
so three two one
you do that six times and we can see in
brain scan images that the stress
response Center lowers and in many cases
deactivates which throws blood back to
the left prefrontal cortex your state of
awareness increases and then you can
move to Inner size number two which is
called Aya AIA which is now in a calm
relaxed State now the first a stands for
awareness of my thoughts emotions
feelings Sensations and what have been
my behaviors for let's say the last five
minutes or hour awareness without shame
blame guilt justification or judgment
pure awareness
calm State then what is my intention
well my intention is to be happy I've
been feeling sad my intentions to be
happy my intention is to be focused not
scattered great let me let me write give
myself one or two intentions then the
next a stands for what's one action to
move me towards that so if your
intentions to be happy why not look up
and smile just look up and smile because
when you look up and smile you release
the neurochemistry of happiness and you
cannot look up and be angry sad mad
discipline you cannot and if you look up
and smile we are wired to look up to
heaven let's say and be hopeful and we
are wired that when we smile the
neurochemistry of happiness is firing
through our bloodstream wow and so if
you just do exercise number one and two
now you get awareness and you calm down
the circuits and then if you learn inner
size number three it's called actors
it's called um
it'll come back to me in just a moment
but the the um the third inner sizes
around it's an actor's studio exercise
basically it's an inner size so any
actor in the world can switch from being
happy or sad or mad or disappointed or
or any modality of physiology that you
want them to take on they can command it
on command right right and so if
somebody's unhappy Could you teach
yourself to be happy in less than three
seconds and the answer is yes if you
chose to so control of emotion control
of emotions and so when we focus on the
the core emotions people have of
Happiness sadness shame uh discuss
contempt love uh we can learn how to
switch between those
on any given moment but most people what
happens they get caught up in this
emotion energy and motion that's
negative or disempowering and then they
think about how they feel and they feel
what they're thinking about and they
keep perpetuating the same pattern and
that's not where it ends and this is
where the problem lays is if you do that
on a regular basis your brain says since
you're repeating this let me just make
this
um you know a habit and I'll just create
that on command free so you're in that
state more frequently and then they
don't know how to interrupt that pattern
and create a new empowered state I'm
always looking for
consistency around all of my content
does that make sense to you if it makes
sense just tell me John that makes total
sense so so far we have you know Define
what your brand stands for if your brand
could speak what would your brand say
about you right if your brand could
speak what would your brand say about
you is your brand fast is your brand
slow is your brand Lexi daisical or just
a just free flow Bahamian you know or is
it more you know
um more sharp edges
um so you have to think about this and
if you're looking to build a personal
brand if you're looking to build a
personal brand then you need to think
about what does my brand stand for what
do I want people to think and feel about
my personal brand so that I own some
space okay in their brain so let me ask
you a question let's have a little bit
of fun when I share with you
um the personal brand
Oprah what do you feel about the brand
what do you feel about the brand
is it a brand that you trust
is it a brand that is fast or calm
like what do you feel when you hear the
word Oprah or what do you feel when you
hear the you know the
um the brand Elon Musk
right what do you what does it make you
feel because every brand develops
consistency and the consistency creates
a feeling and people gravitate towards
how a brand makes them feel right
does a brand make you feel appreciated
that you can trust it uh that it's safe
or that it's risky like Elon Musk is a
risk taker right he's a different brand
than Oprah and yet he's got a huge
following he will make a comment and you
know and cryptocurrency goes through the
roof
right so what does your brand stand for
not having a sales process
not having a sales process what does
that mean
so let me share with you just a sales
process so you need to think in systems
right if this and this and this and this
happens then X is predictable
so let's say you are going to
um do a Instagram live Facebook live
YouTube live LinkedIn live event
you have to think past the event
you have to think past the event then
what
like if somebody comes to your event if
somebody reads your blog if somebody
um reads your Twitter feed if somebody
watches your Tick Tock like then what
like what is the process by which you
share your product service or knowledge
information tidbits around the things
that you want to share then what like
what do you want them to do next
now before you ask people to do
something like give you their email oh I
want your email before you ask them to
you know sign up for this free event or
this paid event
you have to give them value right give
them value give them something tangible
and don't be afraid to give give give
when I wrote my book inner size all of
my books
everything that I write in my books
is
the stuff in my head that I'm working
with clients who pay me five thousand
dollars an hour they just want to go
deeper on the work for me to help them
implement it but I want to give give
give value value value value value and
then I can say hey if you want to go
deeper
get my books you want to go deeper
um get my programs you want to go deeper
get into my coaching program you want to
go deeper hire me as a consultant but
first give the knowledge so here's the
question that you want to ask yourself
what
problem does your product or service
solve What Fear does it eliminate what
uh pain does it eliminate what gain do
people have because of the product
whenever I am looking to give people
content I'm always looking at
understanding
what are the pains fears frustrations
irritations wants needs and aspirations
let me repeat what are the pains fears
frustrations irritations wants needs and
aspirations of the person who wants to
buy whatever it is you know that I have
to offer it doesn't make it there's
somebody sold all this stuff by the way
here's my gratitude coin right gratitude
so so you know whether it's glasses
spray a pen a magnifying glass a
gratitude coin uh the camera that I'm
looking into the computer the stand
somebody had to sell that and every
single product or service
either eliminates a pain fear
frustration irritation or helps people
with a want need or aspiration right so
how do you give somebody content and
information and value in advance
and I'll sit on my board or on my
keyboard and I will ask what is it that
people want and need that I could help
them with
and then I create whether it's blogs
articles videos process maps and I give
them away lack of knowledge and skills
so lack of Knowledge and Skills so when
we don't have let's say we have a goal
any goal it doesn't make a difference
whether it's a relationship goal money
charity whatever it is whenever we lack
the knowledge or the skills there's a
part of us that has self-doubt
self-doubt is what triggers fear because
a worried we don't know enough right so
if we don't know enough we don't have
the knowledge or the skill or we think
we have to have this certain knowledge
or skill that we don't have or that that
we think we need it's going to trigger
self-doubt self-doubt triggers fear fear
deactivates motivational centers in the
brain and deactivates the thinking part
of the brain and our imagination it's
circuits it's all it is is circuits
turning on or off yes and so in the
absence of knowledge and skill of what
to do about it
we default to not taking action because
we're protecting ourselves right and so
all of these little mechanisms you know
these four uh key ones
um cause us to trigger the
procrastination circuit in the brain
they do not take action circuit in the
brain yes right and you know guys are
girls when they're dating you know if
they feel uncertain then they just stay
there well maybe he'll come and talk to
me well maybe she'll come and talk to me
and and it just goes round and round and
round and round how do you recognize and
overcome fear well you you pay attention
and uh you become mindful you sit and
um take some deep breaths and ask
yourself some really good questions what
fears are holding me back like like just
get real get real with yourself don't be
afraid be afraid of the truth
um if you understand the truth and then
you have some Knowledge and Skills to
work through uh you can change that so
the um take six calm the circuits is the
first inner size I'm going to give you a
slight variation of take six come the
circus as you do the next inner size and
it's called Aya awareness intention and
action so
in this particular inner size uh you
take six rhythmic deep breaths to calm
the circuits but here's a slight
variation this is like a little bit more
advanced right so what you do is as you
breathe in you say in the back of your
mind I breathe in calmness
I breathe out fear so it goes like this
so as you are breathing in calmness feel
yourself getting calm from a level 10
fearful to eight to six to four to two
to just letting go of the fear and as
you breathe in calmness and you breathe
out fear I want you to visualize fear
leaving your body just release it
remember it's a neurochemistry that
you're feeling so what you do is you
give your brain the instruction of what
you want so I breathe in calmness I
breathe out fear or I breathe in
calmness I breathe out stress or I
breathe in calmness I breathe out
anxiety just a few seconds of that is
the first part of the inner size but
then what you do
is then you say you know right after you
do that you now become aware and have a
piece of paper next to you and in the
awareness State what you want to do is
become aware awareness of thoughts
feelings emotions
Sensations and behaviors thoughts
feelings emotions Sensations and
behaviors so the first part is you
become aware
no shame no blame no guilt no judgment
no justification just pure awareness
then you ask yourself in this calm
relaxed state where you're able to
respond you ask yourself what's my
intention right now is my intention to
be fearful
no it's my intention to be courageous
yes is my intention to overcome my fear
yes great so you have the awareness you
set one intention not five one one
intention and then the last a is action
what is one action I could take what
action towards achieving whatever goal I
have so maybe one action is I'm gonna
write one uh line of my book one action
is I'm gonna just make one phone call
one action is gonna ask for help one
action to move you away from what you
don't want you have to create marketing
content and offers irresistible offers
that people want to move towards because
it really helps them
it really helps them okay and so when
you are asking somebody to buy something
first did you offer value in advance to
build trust and rapport
second did you create a process for them
to be able to easily move through
from knowledge and information to making
a decision that's good and helpful to
them
and then did you create an offer that is
irresistible for them
an offer that's irresistible for them
that of course you make a profit on you
have to make a profit that you're in
business to make a profit and to help
people so what I want you to do is when
you are thinking about
how to structure your business how to
structure your offers how to structure
your marketing so you stand out from the
competition
now you have an opportunity to really
grow your business so that it actually
works for you unfortunately most
business owners have a job that they
work in their business they don't have a
business they're entrepreneurs I get it
but they have a job
your job is to create really great
marketing that gives people a lot of
what they need to help them
okay with their pains fears frustrations
irritations wants needs and aspirations
your job is to give value in advance on
the channel That your ideal client is at
and then your job is to create a sales
process that makes it easy for them to
do business with you instead of somebody
else
it's easy but it's also easy not to do
the Golden Nugget specifically for
entrepreneurs is something that I was
taught 37 years ago by my mentor who was
a very successful entrepreneur
and he said take one hour a day to level
up your skills
he says when you do one hour a day to
level up your skills whether it's your
mental skills emotional skills strategic
skills whatever it is but one hour a day
after 365 days is 9 40 hour weeks that
you will be ahead of anybody who isn't
doing that so one year it's 9 40 hour
weeks nine of them that's two and a half
months do that for two years three years
four years you will become an expert and
you will make millions of dollars you'll
be happy you'll be not because of the
millions of dollars you'll you'll you'll
be able to live the lifestyle of your
dreams because of who you've become by
upgrading your knowledge and skills and
abilities by just one hour a day
patterns that have been reinforced for
20 30 40 50 years
they're strong patterns they're really
strong patterns so you don't change a 20
or 30 year old pattern
in 20 days by doing it 20 times or 30
times or 50 times when the other pattern
has been recreated and reinforced
thousands and thousands of times you
operate your whole day your whole week
your whole month your whole year based
on the patterns that have been there put
there and reinforced yes so what if I
set you
train your brain for a hundred days
and replace the old disempowering or
negative or destructive patterns with a
new pattern but deliberately yes
deliberately it's called deliberate
conscious evolution I'm deliberately
going to choose to change myself
and if you're committed to that think
about what what would happen if we said
let's say you're out of shape and we
said you know what
um let's go for a one minute walk every
day not an hour one minute yep so the
first you know week we go wow this is
easy one minute walk I can just walk
around my house for a minute here's what
I guarantee will happen at the end of
one week or so let's do a minute and a
half and let's do two minutes and then
let's do three minutes and then at a
hundred days you might be at let's say
you're at an hour a hundred days later
because you actually enjoy it
what do you think would happen to your
beliefs to your confidence your physique
to everything if you were to exercise
gently Lightly for one hour a day change
your life completely transform so let's
start with self-talk let's start with
eliminating our self-deprecating you
know discussions with ourselves and if
we want to change our limiting beliefs
Why not start with asking what
empowering beliefs do I want to have
and then what are ways that I could
actually create that pattern in my brain
so reading an affirmation and closing
your eyes and actually feeling what
that's like if it was true and how would
you behave if that was true and what
kind of comments would you get if that
was true activates not only the left
prefrontal cortex of your brain the
occipital lobe part of your brain the
emotional part of your brain and the
motor cortex of your brain but that is
what it requires to rewire the brain
with a new more empowering pattern stop
buying into the fear that's happening in
the marketplace right now
um coronavirus fear high alert fear what
if I get it what if I know if I get
fired or people buying or people not
buying fear if you're ever what if
negative oh my God oh my God oh my God
what if I get laid off what if I succeed
and then fail what if it doesn't work
what if I disappoint myself stop buying
into the fear I want you to Imagine This
almost 8 billion humans okay eight
billion humans on Earth
not everybody is into the fear not
everybody can't afford stuff not
everybody
um is in Jeopardy whether it's their
business or financially now I understand
a lot of people are hurting so I don't
want to take away from that okay yes
there are a lot of people hurting some
of those people that are hurting have
money some don't some are scared some
are not so what I want you to understand
is whatever your own mindset is about
what's happening out there is what you
are creating in here there are plenty of
people who want what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skill whatever it is that you can offer
them maybe this group doesn't want it
right now maybe this group can't afford
it right now but if you're focusing on
this group in this group you're missing
this group that needs it and wants it
right now more than any other time
so your job and this goes back to my
point number one is you have to stand
out in all of your marketing
because if you don't the group that's
actually looking for you can't see you
in the noise if there is real or
imagined
possibility of discomfort pain
the break on motivation slams shut
and we start to procrastinate
so we have this incredible system that
can give us this motivation the motive
for Action to go forward but we have to
temper it with our ability to recognize
the trigger and the sensation in our
body called a Feeling
that the non-conscious processing part
of the brain that gives us this emotion
called fear all fear is processed at the
non-conscious level of your awareness
and then gives rise into the frontal
lobes
of the feeling that your body has the
average person that has not been trained
feels fear and puts the break on and
goes and Retreats into what they're
comfortable doing
the successful person either they may be
genetically wired to understand feeling
fear and doing it anyway turning Their
Fear into fuel but that's not the
majority of people that's why 90 plus
percent of people fail and stay in that
position but you can take that fuel that
hypersensitive Rocket Fuel I call it and
utilize it to actually motivate you
faster further than you ever got before
but it all starts with being
self-observing awareness of when I'm
uncomfortable how do I respond when I'm
doubtful how do I feel when I've got
negative self-talk going on what's going
on when I'm procrastinating what am I
fearful of what am I most
procrastination by the way is done
because of low self-esteem
if you knew how to get something done
you could do it highly effectively and
on time and you were loving it you'd
freaking do it but most people
procrastinate because they feel doubtful
they don't have all the information
they're procrastinating because they're
worried that if they don't do it
perfectly somebody's going to judge them
creating
irresistible offers
creating irresistible offers what does
that mean
well it means that your greatest cost of
acquiring a new customer is the first
sale
and so have you considered that you can
afford to create an irresistible offer
to get people in
to buy your first product or service
now whenever we are dealing with
creating irresistible offers let's say
you're selling a pen okay you're selling
a pen okay
well you can sell the pen let's say for
a dollar right but what if you sold the
pen and in addition to the pen when you
buy it right now you also get three
videos on how to be a better writer
three videos on how to take ideas from
your head and craft them in such a way
that people will be drawn to what you
write now a pen can be sold as a
commodity or you can create an
irresistible offer by saying not only am
I going to give you the pen but here are
some added value things that you can use
or need all right when you buy my pen
now why would you do that can you
imagine why you would do that
well the hardest sale is the first one
and here's the thing that I want you to
remember when you trust a brand and when
the brand has a product or service that
meets or exceeds your expectations do
you continue to buy from that brand
if the brand exceeds or meets your
expectation do you buy more from that
brand chances are you do so what does
that mean it means that all of the time
and energy and money that you spent to
acquire that new customer you don't have
to pay for that acquisition cost so so
when
okay when you acquire a customer and you
deliver or over deliver not only do they
keep coming to buy from you
but chances are when they are so happy
with what you've done for them
don't you tell your friends or your
family
so now we have repeat business and we
have referrals both of which cost almost
no more money the first three that she
gives
our reason and so the first of the six
steps in rewire your brain is reason and
she says if you don't give your brain a
reason why like why do you want to do
this why must you do this
um it won't actually want to do the work
so if you don't have a reason why it'll
take the path of least resistance and
come up with the reasons why you
shouldn't faster so that's number one
um
second e or second step to re-fire is
engage and she says when you set a goal
she says engage immerse yourself in your
goal and why you want to achieve that
goal and then get support from a group
or a mentor to keep you engaged as you
level up your knowledge and your skills
and your behaviors
the third of her refire to rewire out of
the six step process is
feel and she said get your emotions
behind your goal she says when you get
your emotions behind your goal by think
about all the benefit of everything
you're going to gain who you're going to
become who you're going to be able to
help how you're growing when you get the
emotion behind it and then you engage
and you have your reason why the emotion
is the energy put into motion that is
required to get the momentum and keep
the momentum going consistency across
all of your assets so your business card
your landing pages your ads everything
that you can do
create that brand awareness and those
colors and tie it into your name why
well there's something about our brain
that creates associations so when you
see my face and you see the colors of my
books and you see the colors on my wall
and you see you know our ads or our free
content
or videos there's a consistent theme
around colors and our brain makes that
connection
across all the channels so when you're
building your personal brand be
thoughtful around what is your personal
brand stand for then what are the colors
there could be sounds there's a lot of
sounds companies use
um sounds all right to add to the color
scheme to add to the theme so when we
are creating any type of messaging we
want there to be something that we call
a banner to buyer consistency Banner to
buyer consistency which actually is
going to be the fourth point so I'll
come back to that in just a moment so I
see all of your colors
um yeah when people when people
um our brain
takes snapshots obviously in a you know
um first to create cells of recognition
and when our brain sees consistent
colors over and over and over again it
makes the associations and every single
color means something different to
somebody else so I'm always looking for
consistency around all of my content I
know in my particular case I didn't
believe I wasn't smart enough because
when I moved at five years old from
Israel to Montreal I spoke Hebrew I
didn't read Hebrew or write it but I
spoke it I was just learning the
alphabet I was put into a classroom with
50 kids all speaking French and English
was the second language they were all
speaking so I sat there for two years
looking at the [ __ ] wall Trend and
not only did I feel stupid and I
remember I'm 55 now so this is 50 years
ago I remember kids spitting on me in
the playground because I couldn't speak
English so I'd get into fights all the
time and end up in the principal's
office my parents would be called into
school your son's not doing well in
school he's having fights with the other
kids and I was frustrated and the
teachers didn't have time to work with
me on teaching me a language God I
didn't know the alphabet so I was two
years behind
for my entire schooling up until grade
11 when I quit I said enough is enough
so I had developed this belief that I
wasn't smart enough
holy [ __ ] where did that come from now I
know I'm freaking brilliant and I'm not
saying that in an egotistical way but I
study quantum physics study Neuroscience
I know suckers I love it and I can
understand it but the point I want to
make is I developed this pattern in my
brain that I wasn't good enough just
because of my experience as a
five-year-old
and I carried that on for about 15 years
until I was 19 and I had a mentor you
know ask me why do I think I left school
why do I think I was getting in trouble
why was I working for two dollars and 30
cents an hour when I clearly could speak
and talk and communicate
um and I said well they told me I wasn't
going to amount to much it's only if I
didn't get a college degree I wasn't
going to be smart enough to get a job at
a company and I wouldn't have any
retirement I wouldn't have any ability
to contribute I couldn't make enough
money take care of myself my family so I
I believe what what the people that I'm
supposed to believe told me
so I developed this neuron cluster
around my own self-belief that I was not
smart enough and as a result of that I
couldn't do well in the real world so
what did I do from 12 to 17 I lie stole
cheated sold drugs did break in entries
did counterfeit money uh whatever I
could to make money because every time
you couldn't so I figured out a way I
could
and then I met a man one man who showed
me that I could change my brain he
showed me that I could develop a new
cluster of beliefs that I am good enough
I am worthy enough I am smart enough I
can achieve what I want to achieve I can
learn and it's easy for me I can earn
any amount of money I choose I can learn
whatever I need to learn to earn any
amount of money I choose and so I
started at 19 doing daily affirmations I
recorded my affirmations I listened them
for a freaking you know two three hours
a day in my car as I was driving I wrote
out my goals I recorded my goals I was
taught how to create a new imprint into
my non-conscious brain which is where
your beliefs are anyway
and I started to re-patter re-script and
reshape my belief patterns my perception
of what's possible and while I was doing
that my mentor says great let's upgrade
your knowledge and your skills so we
raise your level of confidence and
certainty I want you to read this book I
want you to listen to this audio I want
you to do this I want you to practice
one hour a day on your skills so you get
better so as I raised myself
confidence and my certainty and my
belief in myself and I developed some
good habits boom one thing started
clicking after another at 19 I made 31
000 bucks at 20 I made 151 000 26 I
started building my own company and did
a billion dollars in sales four years
later what are you focusing on are you
focusing on why you can't are you
focusing on it's not the right time are
you focusing on I don't have the time
the money the money the energy the
knowledge the skills people aren't
buying right now
people aren't buying right now uh things
are so bad what if this happens what if
that happens oh my God what if that
happens if you're in a state of fear
then your Einstein brains turned off and
your Frankenstein brains turned on and
in a state of fear you deactivate
motivation you deactivate Behavior
that is required to take action right
now so what you want to do is you have
to master your mindset right you have to
stop buying into the fear-mongering on
television and radio and so many other
places you have to focus on how you can
achieve your financial goals and your
business goals because you must and
because you will and because you deserve
it I want you to write out just begin
writing out a new money story and I want
you to do this start off your new money
story like this I'm so grateful and
happy for the fact that I am now
and and fill in the blanks feeling doing
experiencing having giving just write
out a little story of your money story
and then what I want you to do every day
for the next just seven days seven days
for five minutes I want you to read that
new money story even though it's not
real right now and then I want to just
imagine what would it be like if this
was real right now what would it be like
and I want you to feel that just use
that as step one
and see what happens
what will happen is you're gonna do two
things I'm gonna get excited which is
great but you also may hear this little
voice that says that's not true you're
not this you can't that and I want you
to be aware of it without judging it
blaming it shaming it or justifying it
just be aware of it and go holy mackerel
listen to that little inner critic that
is trying to hold me back lack of
knowledge and skills
so lack of Knowledge and Skills so when
we don't have let's say we have a goal
any goal doesn't make a difference
whether it's a relationship goal money
charity whatever it is whenever we lack
the knowledge or the skills there's a
part of us that has self-doubt
self-doubt is what triggers fear because
we're worried we don't know enough right
so if we don't know enough we don't have
the knowledge or the skill or we think
we have to have this certain knowledge
or skill that we don't have or that you
know that we think we need it's going to
trigger self-doubt self-doubt triggers
fear fear deactivates motivational
centers in the brain and deactivates the
thinking part of the brain and our
imagination
it's circuits it's all it is is circuits
turning on or off yes and so in the
absence of knowledge and skill of what
to do about it we default to not taking
action because we're protecting
ourselves yep right and so all of these
little mechanisms you know these four uh
key ones
cause us to trigger the procrastination
circuit in the brain they do not take
action circuit in the brain yes let's
say you have some free stuff here but
let's say you know you're talking about
um I don't know ginzu knives but then
over here you're trying to sell okay
um uh signing for a house there there
has to be a banner to buyer consistency
around what it is that you are doing and
offering so if you're going to be
talking okay let's say I'm talking about
you know personal branding to build an
income producing business if I was to
all of a sudden say to you hey uh does
anybody want to go to Egypt with me okay
to look at the pyramids you'd be
scratching your head going why was he
talking about branding and then asked me
to go to Egypt if I wanted to take you
to Egypt I'd be talking about you know
the Great Pyramids and the mystical
um you know um uh theme around that and
then maybe say that so whenever you are
building your brand
make sure that you're creating Banner
means any content that you put out
whether it's videos ads infographics or
anything else right make sure that there
is consistency all the way through to
what you might be offering somebody if
you don't you create brand confusion you
know what I'm talking about
do you know what I'm talking about so
you want to stand for something and you
want to create consistency now that
doesn't mean that you can't have
different product lines so I'll give you
an example I have a winning the game of
Business program I also have a winning
game of weight loss program but I
wouldn't be talking to business owners
about business growth and then say do
you want to look at my winning game of
weight loss program
if I was doing a session on weight loss
or what I prefer to cause weight release
and the science and the evidence of why
people
um uh lose weight and gain weight then
it would make logical sense to offer a
weight loss program so make sure that
you have Banner to buyer consistency
across every one of your channels does
that make sense
don't be doing one thing one day and
another thing the other day another
thing the other day and another thing
the other day being an adaptationist
being an adaptationist I want you to be
a mental adaptationist I want you to be
an emotional adaptationist I want you to
be a business adaptationist because when
you become a business adaptationist and
a mindset an emotional adaptation is
where you adapt and adopt to the
circumstances you control the
environment instead of allowing the
environment to control you mindset is
what separates the best from the rest
right
yes or yes mindset is what separates the
best from the rest
if you think about visualization is
simulation now here is whoa that's good
okay go ahead so visualization is
simulation so when we close our eyes or
even if our eyes are open and we start
to use our Einstein brain the
imagination we now have just activated
one of the biggest centers of our brain
the occipital lobe that's connected to
the motor cortex it's connected to the
motivational Circle the nucleus
accumbens that releases that dopamine
that makes you feel good that makes you
want to take action so if you visualize
yourself achieving the goal if you
visualize yourself behaving in ways that
match the new belief if you even
visualize the words or you take the
words on a sheet of paper and you read
them run your right finger across it run
your left finger across it close your
eyes see it and feel it your brain is
creating a mental movie with the words
and as it creates a mental movie with
the words that's happening in your
subconscious mind
and when you give the subconscious these
instructions a couple things happen
because of the way the brain hierarchy
Works number one is survival but then
number two is safety and then number
three is energy conservation now when
you do something 20 30 40 50 times it
takes about 66 days to 365 days of
repetition to override an old habitual
circuit not 10 days not 21 days 66 to
365. so if you visualize yourself
achieving the goal feeling the success
that you want to feel seeing the belief
on the screen of your mind you are
actually creating a neural network
through the science of neuroplasticity
and the networks that you reinforce
become the most dominant networks and
since your brain wants to conserve
energy
if you do this on a consistent basis
your brain says okay you're doing this
so often let me just make this automatic
let me set aside the old beliefs let me
replace it with the new beliefs and now
you've deliberately and consciously
evolved yourself one of the things that
is is really I mean just based on what
you said there is something in business
whether it's for sales people on the
phones or sales people in person on the
phone it's called call reluctance and in
person it's po it's called Contact
reluctance and so if you think about
what does that mean so I have a call
reluctance I have a reluctance to call
somebody that I don't know and so when
some people think about calling somebody
they don't know when they're prospecting
or meeting somebody they don't know
if you think about what is it that is
actually happening that causes them to
to feel that so as soon as they have the
thought their neurochemistry kicks in
because the meaning that they have is if
I call somebody that I don't know and
they hang up on me they yell at me they
say something nasty to me then they are
attacking my identity and in most cases
they have Associated the attack on their
identity in a negative way
such as well maybe it's true that I'm
not good enough maybe it's true that I'm
not smart enough maybe it's true that
I'm not worthy so they have a negative
association with somebody's response
that they don't even know
about who they are so the first thing we
work on is let's focus on your
self-esteem
because the self-esteem that's being
attacked my self-esteem and self-worth
is being attacked so when my self-esteem
and self-worth is being attacked in a
negative way or unpleasant way
I'm going to process that as danger in
my brain now when you understand the
brain's number one responsibility is to
move you away from danger or pain that's
number one on its hierarchy of how it
behaves so if there is real or imagined
pain or discomfort your brain says stop
put the brakes on go the other way
that's what's happening so the first
thing we do is we teach people number
one let's change the meaning that you
have around what somebody else's
response is
around who you are or what you're doing
or what you're offering them so the
first thing we work on is change the
meaning you change the feeling for the
people who think that the law of
attraction is
um you know think believe in your
achieve first I'm going to tell you
that's [ __ ] so let's call it I love
this man
um but I want you to think of your brain
just a little bit differently and think
of it this way let's say you love rock
and roll and let's say rock and roll's
on station 95.5 if you're on station
92.1 that might be classical
if you're on station 98.7 that might be
punk rock but a 92.5 that's rock and
roll
so imagine coherence just means locking
your electromagnetic spectrum of your
brain lock it and load it on exactly
what you want so what's the vision
what's the goal what are the beliefs
what are the emotions that create
coherence so you're locked and loaded to
the frequency of the universe that is
matching that goal part one part two is
when you get locked and loaded you've
actually activated the Einstein brain
connected to the motor cortex connected
to the dopamine release in your body
and when that happens okay now you're in
coherence but there's another part that
happens in this Einstein part of the
brain that's actually what the latest
neuroscientists and psychologists are
thinking is connected to this GPS part
of our brain to the frequency of where
all of the tools resources people are
that resonate with that
um frequency so
we've been evolving for what two and a
half million years since Homo erectus to
now 108 billion humans on Earth with a
brain that's been changing and growing
and my belief is we're just scratching
the proverbial surface and we talk about
you know a little quantum mechanics or
quantifism with entanglement how we're
all connecting we're all tuning into the
frequencies that are us and within us
and all around us now when we learn to
use our brain better uh it's just
mind-boggling how we can achieve goals
and dreams that we thought were
impossible to achieve before this is the
fun part now I have a philosophy that
every moment every precious nanosecond
and moment is perfect
and so when I connect to the Perfection
of that moment there's really nothing to
do it's to be aware and to allow to
surrender but not to give up surrender
but to understand that you know as you
know we are talking right now
uh the oceans don't need any instruction
what to do the uh the planets that are
moving in in their elliptical orbits
around the sun don't need yours or my
intervention the universe the Milky Way
galaxy that's you know flowing through
the universe at a million and a half
miles per hour doesn't need yours in my
instruction so that means that ever
every moment is perfect so I want to
connect to the Perfection of every
single moment be aware of that every
single moment and realize that many
things are not to my taste many things I
don't understand but that doesn't mean
that the moment isn't perfect every
human being has a relationship with
money and money is something that
um
envelops people's brains about what they
buy what they don't buy whether they buy
you know a business class or first class
or a regular economy seats whether
they're always looking for the cheapest
or the most expensive the nicest uh or
average how much they will tip how much
they won't we all have
a money story that we've developed
mostly from our parents and the people
that we live near and we developed this
relationship around money and our
beliefs around money you know are we
good enough to earn that amount uh are
we worthy enough to earn that amount
um uh is it is it um worth it or not and
so one of the things that Mary Morrissey
um says that um we should do she says
for seven days write down the thoughts
you have about money and notice when
you're thinking
um and notice what you are thinking and
notice that the money story you're
telling yourself is it positive negative
is it abundance thinking or limited
thinking is it scarcity thinking or is
it
but fill in the blank and so once you
know your money story and this is also
something that one of our um
psychiatrists who works with us Dr David
Krueger says once you know the story The
Money story that's when you can start to
be aware of it and go wow where did I
get these limiting beliefs about money
about my value where do I get these
limiting beliefs of what I can afford
and what I can't Where'd I get these
limiting beliefs around
um
um how I behave with money because you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see my last one-on-one with the
amazing John ass rap check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there we all own the most powerful
bio computer in the world in the
universe
and most people don't know how to change
their brain to change their income